j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour l état donne la vie
[Musique]
super retour du prince en exil alors
sarko alors il fait ça très très faim
quoi subtilement il délègue aux autres
sarkozysme il passé si la libye qui
parle de stature internationale
le qatar qui parle de sa stature
économique le juge gentil qu'est part de
son statut juridique
bon nicolas est mis en examen pour abus
de faiblesse je suis désolé ça c'est un
peu normal quand je vois pas très bien
comment on peut devenir président de la
république sans abusé de la faiblesse
des électeurs c'est c'est dans le
package que ça toute façon les gens sont
méchants qui ce qu'ils sont méchants
avec nicolas pour une fois qu'il aurait
abusé d'un riche veille quoi mais ça
c'est la supériorité de la gauche sur la
droite quoi c'est la gauche elle arrive
aussi abusé de la faiblesse des pauvres
faire
alors
battant nicolas il se foule pas trop
quoi son seul argument de défense et de
ses potes c'est mais est-ce que vous
m'imaginez arnaqué une vieille dame
bah évidemment
tenté capable d'installer des tentes à
kadhafi dans les jardins de l'elysée
pour lui sucer des contrats commerciaux
et tu serais pas capable d'aller faire
les poches et le même et du cac 40 cac
faut se réveiller quand je veux dire
alors il ya la présomption d'innocence
ya pas il aurait
moi je moi je veux bien à part pour du
blé je vois pas très bien l'intérêt
d'aller passer du temps avec une mémé
bain en plus qu'est ce qui va lui
raconter enfin je vais lui qui arrive
pas à rester en place trois secondes
j'imagine mal passé une après midi avec
une mémé qui a besoin de 20 minutes pour
terminer une phrase que c'est
à droite tout de suite le scandale
scandale nadine morano compare cette
affaire au scandale d'outreau
heureusement qu'elle n'a jamais envie de
faire une carrière judiciaire elle
puisque juge d'instruction elle serait
capable de dire dans cette famille le
problème ce ne sont pas les parents
pédophile c'est les enfants gérontophile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors sarko qui a déclaré la pluie finit
toujours par laisser la place au soleil
maintenant au moins on sait qui est le
parolier de carla bruni
jean marc ayrault a lancé une
mobilisation générale pour l'emploi et
jean marc ayrault le je veux dire le
jean marc ayrault qui pousse un cri de
mobilisation c'est à peu près aussi
crédible que de voir le pape inaugure
une partouze
l'europe on dit parce que chiffres ces
fonds non mais franchement chypre quoi
alors évidemment tout le monde puisque
est scandalisée tout le monde s'agite
oui mais c'est un scandale maintenant
eux aussi l'ont endroit à l'austérité
moi je vois pas le problème là dessus si
on applique l'austérité à chypre ils
vont revenir à ce qu'ils faisaient avant
que la feta et des herbes de provence
pas du coup ça fait beaucoup jaser
mélenchon mélenchon qui traite les
ministres de finances de l'eurogroupe de
17 salopards 17 salopards on voit que
niveau cinéma au front de gauche sont
encore des séances de rattrapage en tout
cas mélenchon au niveau sémantique parce
qu'il a fait des petites phrases genre
années 30 tout ça un peu des trucs que
même le fn hausse +1 même le fn mais le
fn il a perdu toute sa verve quoi
aujourd'hui c'est le fn c'est quoi ces
metallica qui chante du jennifer près
c'est un sacré coup
parlant de moeurs musicale dépravé
mariage gay
bon personnellement je pensais qu'on
avait fait le tour du sujet qu'on avait
compris mais mais là non non la sas à
compter du mariage gay y font une manif
reçoit avec ce truc façon la droite fait
vraiment fait vraiment n'importe quoi
moi je veux pas être celui qui rajoute
de l'hépatite sur la gpa mais
cette manif avait des relents très
réactionnaire très nauséabond quoi très
way gaz et des mioches je veux dire en
plus catholique
il ya eu cette photo terrible de boutin
au sol comme ça au milieu à
l'horizontale c'est pas son truc cuinchy
parlante pma et encore une histoire de
bébé congelé ce qui me choque toujours
dans ces histoires c'est patent
l'infanticide que la congélation
pourquoi la mer qu'on gèle son gosse non
mais elle attend une offre de spanghero
[Applaudissements]
alimentation toujours on l'a retrouvé
une souris morte dans un sachet de pâtes
alors forcément l'acheteuse tout de
suite voilà comme les réactions aux
abois c'est dégueulasse eux elle a une
idée du prix de la viande
pour une fois qu'on lui fournit des
protéines en rab
moi je répondais annie j'enverrai une
facture
économie normale alors l'allemagne s'en
sort mieux c'est normal quand tu as
perdu deux guerres de suite tu te remets
peut-être plus facilement en question
économie parallèle la tacc du rer d dans
ce pays même les délinquants perdre la
boule en dire moi j'ai regardé l une des
tutus ce nom mais vous savez de nous
elle va le truc qui relie saint-denis
alleyson saint denis à l'essonne là le
machin le plus friqué qu'elle traverse
et châtelet les halles
qu'est-ce que tu braques à châtelet les
halles le relais
façon je me disais contre la délinquance
dans ce pays on a tout essayé mais pas
la charia
non parce que si on commence à couper un
bras à chaque délinquant en terme de
réinsertion
à parfaire capitaine crochet dans la
parade chez mickey
et encore je pense pas aux
multirécidivistes
eux ils n'auront aucune possibilité de
réinsertion hurle foutu mais comme
ballon
les hommes troncs qui rebondissent dans
les filets que
culturellement
semaine difficile on a perdu koh lanta
tout ça parce qu'un candidat est mort
bon fallait s'y attendre quoi force de
se faire bouffer fallait bien que les
asticots prennent leur revanche un jour
le type le premier jour il arrive il met
les pieds dans l'eau bam quoi le mec
vraiment pas doué pour faire touristes
quand même
non mais c'est indécent crevé au
cambodge entente paie
ses petits pieds ou quoi enfin qui vit
plus
ascenseur social il ya encore des
possibilités de promotion dans ce pays
gad elmaleh sort avec charlotte
casiraghi c'est-à-dire hop hop hop hop
encore un peu de patience si on aura le
prince de monaco
[Applaudissements]
ceci dit je m'inquiète dans le grand
père qui est sorti à grace kelly la
fille avec vincent lindon la petite
fille gad elmaleh ou next
sigad et sa copine aux argos il va
sortir avec qui
nabil art
kev adams
hier l'accord et menacent d'attaquer les
etats-unis la corée les états unis alors
ils ont envoyé de nice rodman grand
basketteur là pour faire une médiation
je comprends que les coréens se vexe
quoi quand l'amérique envoie comme
représentant officiel un ancien
basketteur habillé comme un dictateur
zaïrois
même nous on n'a pas eu l'idée d'envoyer
philippe katerine négocier avec aqmi
match de foot france espagne espagne 1
france 0 alors hollande qui a prédit un
match nul assez tôt lui ça si c'est nul
c'est bien avec lui l'essentiel c'est
pas de gagner mais de pas perdre tout
seul
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une pensée émue quand même pour
l'espagne quoi c'est émouvant si l'avion
d'espagnol il crache le pays perd la
moitié de son pib
puis les footballeurs quoi c'est c'est
moi je veux pas les dénigrer pour une
fois qu'on voit des milliardaires suez
comme des manutentionnaires quoi c'est
le footballeur c'est un peu le 2 en 1 de
la lutte des classes l'arrogance du
patronat avec le mauvais goût de la
classe s'ouvrir
bonne nouvelle ah oui il faut bien
terminer en beauté alors j'ai vu ça dans
le figaro du mercredi la manchette
suivante les trois dernières semaines
pour diminuer votre isf enfin
heureusement qui a encore une presse
optimiste dans ce pays alors est pas
belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu